I think it's going to taste like a
late-night snack after a pro wrestling
match
what drum persons with that combination
together
why that's a hard thing why I don't know
but for some rules I don't think that
it's like it would like be good for you
who's of protein purposes I'm from the
south and I feel like people in the
south would be like totally down oh yeah
I think what we're learning now is that
America will put anything in the shape
what are these lumps please don't
mistake that then you're like dipping
buddies are you getting like black spots
what is that
shame mmm I like to be perfect yeah I
like to be Georgie
oh hey that works there could be a part
of it I imagine this is what making out
with a lumberjack
tastes like you've just ruined all of my
lumberjack fantasy you know neckties
like just straight up caramel it does
you know that you what am i this is a
drink for like a baseball coach a little
league team
I would prefer an intravenous protein
injection over this it's kind like
putting bacon on a doughnut well you
don't think it'll work but it works
I think experimentation is good not with
meat sticks what do you think this says
about America we have a long way to go
but like also the way we're going out
there I think we won't know we're there
we're there I love beef jerky and I love
ice cream if it ain't broke don't fix it
there people would like to have sex and
mascot costumes like there's this is for
somebody somebody like this absolutely
you
Wow